friends of Ben Simmons yeah how did that
relationship start so Tristan Thompson
is a good friend of mine he has some
friends and they invited me to go
bowling one day in L.A and and Ben was
there and then that's when we became
friends where do you stay in with like
maybe he's misunderstood all the Ben
Simmons you know drama as far as like
you know the the last game whatever like
happens right and on top of it yo he had
a real back problem with this he needed
surgery and he showed me the picture of
the stuff like it's crazy I'm glad he
didn't play the next game but maybe
would have been injured and stuff for a
long time would you say the media
portrayal has been unfair I mean yeah
he's amazing basketball players we got
so much [ __ ] y'all forgot about that
[ __ ] he's a relationship ongoing like do
you is he probably your best homeboy in
the NBA him and Trenton Thompson I just
saw him two days ago he's in this room
right here he came to check me in the
studio has he ever tried to hop in what
to do music he get some bars off nah
maybe be joking about it I don't think
so